[Música]
el descontento social en américa latina'
están nuevamente en efervescencia
después de los cierres y los
confinamientos debido a la pandemia de
kobe 19 los ciudadanos de la región
volvieron a las calles para demostrar su
descontento recientemente panamá se unió
a la lista de países que son testigos de
manifestaciones de paros de transportes
huelgas descontento generalizado la
razón puede ser tal vez el lento
despegue de las economías de los países
de la región la inflación la inseguridad
la incertidumbre política los cambios
políticos y la falta de liderazgo
regional sólo por mencionar algunos de
los aspectos la disminución también en
la capacidad adquisitiva que impacta
directamente en el consumo en el
bolsillo de los ciudadanos
latinoamericanos el crecimiento moderado
de las economías pero sobre todo la
falta de empatía por parte de las
autoridades con matices diferentes el
reclamo en el fondo es esencialmente el
mismo el gobierno parece o los gobiernos
parecen no entender o escuchar los
reclamos de los que están en las calles
dicen que hay una desconexión entre los
estados los gobiernos y la ciudadanía
cómo alcanzar entonces una sintonía
entre las partes esta américa latina' al
borde de un gran estallido social por el
descontento generalizado podrán entonces
los cambios políticos dar un poco de
tranquilidad marcar un rumbo marcar un
norte y sobre todo marcar un nuevo
liderazgo político en la región lo vamos
a analizar hoy en el debate de france 24
para conversar sobre este tema saludamos
a paula ruiz ella es directora de la
escuela de relaciones internacionales de
la facultad de finanzas gobierno y
relaciones internacionales de la
universidad externado de colombia ella
se encuentra en la ciudad de bogotá en
la capital colombiana y desde ciudad de
panamá se conecta a esta conversación
danilo toro él es sociólogo y también
analista es investigador de la
universidad tecnológica de panamá
les recuerdo que ustedes también hacen
parte de esta conversación pueden dejar
todos sus preguntas y sus comentarios a
través de las redes sociales estamos en
twitter en instagram y en facebook en
donde nos encuentran como arroba
france24 guión bajo s sant y luego que
es mi cuenta personal la etiqueta para
que hagan sus comentarios se les
recuerdo numeral el debate efe 24 en
youtube también pueden seguir nuestra
señal en streaming en vivo también
aprovecho para saludar a las personas
que nos están escuchando a través de
nuestro podcast nuestro contenido ya
está disponible en diferentes
plataformas no se encuentran en app el
podcast spotify deezer y en ti un end
comienzo entonces el debate y
simplemente para conocer puntos de
opinión para la partida o punto de
partida de nuestro programa de hoy
entonces la bienvenida a paula ruiz en
la ciudad de bogotá en colombia y paula
punto de partida para conocer opiniones
generales de la situación que hay en
américa latina porque vemos que los
países presentan diferentes tipos de
manifestaciones
uno son por los transportes otros son
por los incrementos en los precios de la
canasta básica pero hay unos puntos en
común la inflación la inseguridad y un
descontento generalizado esta américa
latina' al borde de estallar en las
calles por un reclamo en conjunto un
reclamo ciudadano en conjunto
bueno muy buenas tardes santiago muchas
gracias por la invitación bueno yo creo
que
bueno perdimos la señal con paula en la
ciudad de bogotá pasó entonces a darle
la bienvenida a nuestro segundo invitado
mientras vamos restableciendo la
conexión con paula danilo toro como lo
decía se encuentra en ciudad de panamá
danilo muchas gracias por acompañarnos
en el programa la misma pregunta que le
estaba haciendo a paula como punto de
partida está en la región de américa
latina en un punto de ebullición se está
gestando un un quiebre un rompimiento un
estallido a nivel de la sociedad
latinoamericana por múltiples reclamos a
los gobiernos
sí buenas tardes un placer detrás con
ustedes y lo que puedo contestarte a la
pregunta es que efectivamente américa
latina está viviendo un momento de
estallido pero ojo no confundir el
chispas o la encendida el detonante o
los problemas estructurales
lo que ten
tenemos hoy día a lo que hemos llegado
no es por lo que está ocurriendo en este
momento en el caso de panamá como el
caso de varios países de américa latina
a mi criterio hay un acumulado de
catastrófica historia en la que hay una
serie de factores que preparan
construyen
este escenario en el que inevitablemente
se llega con desbordes con
desequilibrios con inestabilidad un
desgarre social y corruptora así que lo
que estamos enfrentando ahorita son las
chispas de encendido no el problema
estructural que es lo que está
explotando es un poco como si viéramos
el corte a lo largo de un volcán o si
vemos la erupción la lava las piedras el
humo el fuego pero antes de que eso se
le diera una acumulación de gases pero
ese proceso de acumulación se dio
durante el año
d'angelo le voy a dar paso entonces a
paula para conocer la opinión de ella de
este punto de partida y le dejó sobre la
mesa la siguiente pregunta y es que
vayamos entonces mirando de forma de
fondo de estructura qué es lo que está
molestando a los ciudadanos
latinoamericanos de fondo que tienen en
común las sociedades en méxico en panamá
en colombia en perú en argentina incluso
en brasil para que vayamos entonces
armando la estructura de lo que puede
llegar a ser este descontento general en
la región paula de nuevo bienvenida al
programa nos estaba contando entonces
cuál es su opinión sobre esta posible
estallido en las calles de los
ciudadanos latinoamericanos por
múltiples factores ya lo decía danilo
hay muchos aspectos pero de fondo es una
acumulación de cosas cuál es su opinión
bueno santiago lo que te decía
anteriormente es que creo que el título
del programa que ponéis protestas en
américa latina una región asfixiada pues
eso es cierto en este momento pues lo
que estamos viendo en común en todos los
países por recibirse no en un cartel de
unas protestas en en panamá y es no es
guerra no es pandemia es corrupción la
gente en últimas lo que está pidiendo a
los gobiernos es que todas esas en el
caso por ejemplo de panamá que es un
modelo de desarrollo es importante para
la región pues lleno nos está dando una
distribución adecuada de los recursos no
es un tema que el país en este caso no
tenga o no cuente con las capacidades
económicas para garantizar empleo el
tema se llama distribución el tema se
llama desigualdad y lo que estamos
viendo en la mayoría de países de la
región pues es algo muy estructural en
el sentido de que las manifestaciones en
las protestas van dirigidas a lo mismo
como lo decías una introducción que los
escuchen que tomen acciones que en
efecto pues se busquen atacar la
corrupción que en américa latina pues es
uno de los males más graves que tenemos
y que se junta además pues con otra
serie de manifestaciones o de
problemáticas de tipo también económico
en el cual pues vemos que se están
subiendo los precios de los combustibles
de los alimentos ya estas protestas y
estas demandas sociales en efecto lo que
vemos en perú o lo que vemos en ecuador
es empezaron a tocar el bolsillo de la
ciudad y ya cuando sienten que lo que
ganan no les da para vivir en el mismo
estilo de vida que tenían anteriormente
no se trata de vivir en riqueza se trata
un poco de vivir pues con dignidad
entonces lo que estamos viendo es una
molestia estructural frente a unos
problemas históricos
paula una molestia estructural pero que
tanto hay acá de una molestia como dice
danilo por una acumulación de hechos que
vienen dándose a lo largo de los años de
escándalos de corrupción de economías
que no logran despegar o lo hacen por
unos cuantos años y vuelven y caen en
los espirales de la recesión y que tanto
es
una falta de comprensión por parte de la
ciudadanía del contexto de la coyuntura
en la que está en la que está en el que
está el mundo entero que estamos
saliendo de una pandemia que está
volviendo a repuntar en el número de
casos y que hay una guerra que no
pensábamos que iba a afectar tanto a
puntos lejanos como américa latina' y si
no se está dando un coletazo a nivel
económico que nos está impactando en
diferentes formas que tanto es esa falta
de comprensión de la gente sobre la
coyuntura que tenemos a entender que la
economía mundial no va bien no solamente
la del país la inflación es en todos los
estados en todos los países del mundo no
solamente en américa latina'
yo creería que el problema es más que la
falta de conocimiento por parte de la
ciudadanía al final es un tema de
frustración y es un tema de rabia frente
a la manera como los gobiernos están
respondiendo frente a sus demandas
frente a la manera cómo los gobiernos
dilatan decisiones que tienen que tomar
precisamente frente a cómo van a mejorar
las condiciones sociales de la
ciudadanía entender que en este momento
la inflación a nivel global pues está
implicada como un conflicto que inició
rusia en ucrania para una población que
vemos en los carteles y en las
manifestaciones que simplemente están
pidiendo más empleo que simplemente
están pidiendo que se tomen medidas más
decididas para mejorar su día a día pues
es difícil pedir que entiendan que hay
una situación internacional que de
alguna u otra forma les está afectando
de alguna manera lo que vemos en el caso
de panamá es que todo empieza como en la
mayoría de países en la región por el
aumento de los precios de los
combustibles en el caso de panamá
observamos que aún así el gobierno
revocó en la medida entonces nos
preguntamos y por qué siguen entonces
las protestas porque se unen los
maestros porque se unieron los
trabajadores de construcción porque se
unen indígenas porque se unen otro tipo
de sectores e industrias que también
tienen demandas y lo que vemos es que
pues va más allá de un tema económico lo
que estamos viendo es simplemente cómo
se empiezan a juntar factores económicos
políticos frente a unas necesidades
sociales que no han sido atendidas son
digamos pues de manera asertiva un
escenario muy similar lo veíamos en
chile hace algunos hace un par de años
el incremento en el pasaje del metro de
santiago generó fue el punto de
estallido de esta gran oleada de
manifestaciones que llevó al escenario y
que estamos ahora a un cambio de la
constitución del país precisamente por
un descontento a todo nivel que
involucró no solamente a estudiantes a
campesinos o grupos indígenas sino a
diferentes sectores de también del
sector industrial en chile regresó con
santiago con danilo en la ciudad de
panamá para preguntarle y retomar la
pregunta que hemos dejado sobre la mesa
y ver esos puntos estructurales que
usted dice que hay un hartazgo
que viene con el paso de los años y
panamá es en este momento el país que
está dando una mayor evidencia de esos
manifestaciones vemos en varios países
en cuba en méxico en perú hace hace
pocos días precisamente por el aumento
también del precio del combustible pero
entonces cuáles son esos problemas de
fondo d angelo bien en primera instancia
en que tener presente qué
y lo que estamos viendo son los
chispazos son los encendidos son este es
el momento en que en que algo derrama el
vaso y ha ocupado del líquido
y eso hay que diferenciarlo del problema
estructural el premetro una vez que
tiene panamá la cual ha sido
la inequidad es un país que
históricamente ha tenido terribles
inequidades
muchos tienen muy poco y muy pocos
tienen un bus o un país con una con un
producto interno bruto considerable un
país con una distribución de riqueza
terriblemente distribuida y te
encuentras con importantes proporciones
de población que se han visto
desprovistas de las necesidades básicas
de poder cubrir sus necesidades básicas
pero no en el último año
la última crisis de la última
sí
que hacía que antes no ocurriera
destruyendo el colchón de tuvieras que
abordar es pasar ciertas situaciones
apremiantes de una u otra forma se
encontraba en salida o el pequeñito de
conmigo tenía una rama que saltaba a
otros sectores que ocurrió con la
pandemia de covite que trajo una
catastrófica situación económica y
sometió al desempleo
de personas
y a otra la llevó al r
en estas condiciones la tolerancia a la
corrupción
y estamos teniendo problemas para
entender la idea hay un problema con la
conexión tal parece que hoy la
tecnología no está de nuestro lado para
pedirle a las personas del área técnica
que revisen su conexión por favor porque
no le estamos comprendiendo la idea
completa de lo que está diciendo
mientras tanto continúa entonces con
pablo en la ciudad de bogotá mientras la
área técnica revisa esta conexión a ver
qué podemos solucionar para tener un
programa un poco más fluido paula retoma
entonces la comunicación con usted en
bogotá no sé si la pregunta que le voy a
hacer es
tiene una respuesta puntual pero me
llama la atención
entender cómo es la américa latina que
estamos construyendo una américa latina
en donde están estos reclamos de
desigualdad están estos reclamos
de la necesidad de tener una mejor
representación por parte de los
gobiernos donde el espectro político va
y viene de un gobierno a otro donde no
hay una continuidad en los proyectos qué
clase de región es la que estamos
construyendo claramente no va por buen
camino si lo que se ve en las calles son
solamente reclamos y mejoras y se piden
cambios urgentes
bueno santiago aquí lo interesante de
todos los casos que se mencionan el de
ecuador el de perú el de panamá
anteriormente pues también mencionabas
el de chile es que lo que estamos
observando es que se están viendo cada
vez más en la calle unas manifestaciones
muy espontáneas por parte de la sociedad
civil y no necesariamente hacen parte de
ellas unos premios específicos o unos
representantes sino que absolutamente
todos salen a las calles todos tienen
algo algo que manifestar tienen algo que
pedir tienen algo que reclamarle a sus
gobiernos en el caso de los países de
américa latina ha habido digamos
históricamente un reclamo alrededor por
ejemplo de solucionar unos problemas que
están muy relacionados a lo que ha sido
la evolución social de nuestros países y
lo mencionaba el profesor antes de que
se le fuera la señal y son los temas de
pobreza son los temas de desigualdad y
por eso digamos que las demandas van
dirigidas a tomar medidas urgentes para
luchar contra la corrupción uno de los
temas de lo que vemos pues en américa
latina es que tenemos unos ciclos de
crecimiento muy marcados era de
principios de este ciclo por ejemplo fue
un momento positivo para la economía de
casi todos los países latinoamericanos
pero después cuando llega la pandemia y
crisis económicas y demás pues lo que
vemos es que en efecto de sus tiempos
dorados pues no prosperaron una
inversión por lo tanto pues estamos
empezando a ver esas consecuencias la
gente lo que simplemente está buscando y
lo que vemos en todos estos casos es que
el ejecutivo está bajo la mira en el
caso de perú pues vemos que uno de los
reclamos que hacen los manifestantes es
que se ha rodeado de ministros que están
poco cualificados para los cargos para
los cuales nos quieren poner lo que
estamos bien cuando en el caso también
de perú es que pues se toman a veces
medidas represivas que van en contra de
las libertades de los individuos
entonces sí estamos viendo pues es
simplemente
como lo dije anteriormente una
frustración generalizada frente a ver
que hay muchas promesas pero nada a
cambio
paula creo que ya retomamos también la
conexión con danilo le hago la misma
pregunta a los dos esto son unas
manifestaciones que tienen un componente
generacional que tanto hay de componente
aquí de generación de
jóvenes pidiendo mejores condiciones o
es un llamado general de la ciudadanía
de cada uno de estos países daniel lo
que piensa al respecto
cuando no persigo una situación de
jóvenes no percibo veo veo veo a todos
desde punto de vista desde grupos de
edad los veo a todos comprometidos en
una situación bastante homogénea las
diferencias si las veo desde el punto de
vista del sector social lo nuevo acá es
que las capas medias están más
involucradas en este tipo de reclamos
porque se han visto pauperizadas se han
ido empobreciendo desde ovi para acá de
una manera muy acelerada y eso ha
estimulado esta especie de
intolerancia a las fallas a las
imprudencias a los desplantes a la
corrupción a los errores a la gente
prudencia
de la administración del estado entonces
la capacidad de respuesta de los
gobiernos porque porque hacen culto de
la improvisación porque la corrupción la
cultura de corrupción los ha cegado
porque existe una fragmentación política
y hay una dispersión política y entonces
eso hace que las oportunidades de
liderazgo se vean cada vez más difíciles
de poder distinguir surge el liderazgo
sorpresivo o liderazgo fugaces o
liderazgo muy débiles
hay también una sensación de inseguridad
tanto desde el punto de vista económico
como del punto de vista social ese es un
tema que vamos a analizar más adelante
lo tengo para verlo en nuestra agenda y
paula su opinión sobre este tema
generacional usted como colombiana no sé
si tenga la misma impresión que en
colombia vimos este estallido social que
tuvo un particular foco en la ciudad de
cali que es una de las tres ciudades más
importantes del país
antiguamente colombia o unos años atrás
en colombia no era habitual la protesta
no era habitual que la gente saliera a
las calles a manifestarse de la manera
como lo hicieron en ese estallido que
tuvo que enfrentar el presidente
saliente iván duque porque
tradicionalmente en colombia protestar
era de izquierda era de comunista era de
los guerrilleros aquí hay un cambio de
generación hay un cambio de perspectiva
por lo menos en el caso colombiano en
otros países es más habitual en
argentina la protesta es mucho más
normalizada digámoslo así dentro de la
sociedad argentina
bueno muy interesante es la pregunta que
hace santiago porque en efecto a pesar
de que vemos algunos puntos que
coinciden entre un país y otro sí creo
que los que inician digamos que ese
punto focal inicial en cada una de las
protestas si están muy marcadas hacia un
sector o hacia una población específica
en el caso por ejemplo que tú mencionas
en colombia pues son protestas que
inician principalmente por los jóvenes
que reclaman la falta de oportunidades
frente a temas de educación y frente a
temas de empleo de empleabilidad a la
cual se unen otros gremios y se unen
pues otros grupos en el caso por ejemplo
de ecuador pues veíamos que fueron los
líderes indígenas los que iniciaron
estas primeras manifestaciones ante la
subida de los precios de los
combustibles pero a los cuales también
se empiezan a unir otros sectores
demandando otro tipo de cuestiones
sociales en el caso de panamá pues vemos
que es iniciado un movimiento por los
transportadores al cual también se
determinan uniendo otros grupos pero
siempre digamos ahí hay hay un inicio y
hay un punto que es como lo dice al
profesor hay una mecha que estalla todo
pero a través de la cual terminan
permeando se los demás en el caso de
panamá por ejemplo es muy interesante
ver qué es lo que se está pidiendo es
simplemente una mesa unificada de dial
una mesa en la cual participen los
gremios los sindicatos los jóvenes las
organizaciones empresariales una mesa
alrededor de la cual esté auspiciada por
la iglesia que es bastante interesante
porque no se están cerrando pues en sus
canales de diálogo pero sí que que
digamos que es interesante lo que
preguntas de quiénes son los
protagonistas en cada una de las
protestas y sí que vemos que en cada
país si hay unos protagonistas a pesar
de que se vuelve masivo y hay una
representatividad de la sociedad porque
si hay representaciones de distintos
grupos si digamos que los que inician
los que siembran la primera semilla
frente a esas manifestaciones pues sí
están muy caracterizadas en cada país
muy particular y eso me lleva al
siguiente bloque del programa y es el
otro lado y es el estado como responde
el estado de cada uno o los gobiernos de
cada uno de estos países danilo usted
hablaba de la capacidad de respuesta que
tienen y vemos que la mayoría de los
gobiernos de la región han promulgado
medidas de gasto precisamente para dar
más subsidios para dar ayudas económicas
y es más gasto más dinero pero esto qué
tan sostenible puede ser esto es
simplemente una medida no sé cómo lo vea
usted a mediano o corto muy corto plazo
porque pues éstas no son economías que
tengan grandes capitales para estar
gastando porque la necesidad de
inversión en otras áreas es mucho más
importante como lo que usted danilo
ojo en el caso de panamá el
chispazo vino fue por un lado de capas
medias
grupo magisterial y sobre todo grupos de
docentes de profesores que han tenido
una larga dinámica de juicio con el
gobierno los gobiernos y en el interior
del país a ellos se les sumaron
otro tipo de organizaciones
desde capas medias y a lo interno de
quienes protesta también ven
contradicciones híbridos
experiencias no es un movimiento de
mujeres miedo
que tienen en común todos tienen un
enorme disgusto frente al estado de
servicio que les lettres en cara por no
cubrir necesidades básicas por el
desempleo por no pagar por no poder
pagar y lo costosa que la vida hoy día
por no tener salidas y la corrupción
ahora resulta grotesca aunque fuese
menor que antes posiblemente no es que
ahora haya más corrupción que la
corrupción es percibida está como
grotesca como ofensiva como opulento
como opulencia tirado a la cara de la
gente en situaciones en que la gente
sufre carestía no sé hay una
institucionalidad muy débil hay un
estado muy débil hay un estado que no es
capaz de responder con políticas
públicas debidamente sostenida hay unas
hay una ayuda atmósfera de
administración
saturada improvisación entonces
con la pérdida de esta estabilidad los
gobiernos como el caso de panamá han
sido lentos ha agotado el tiempo ha
apostado a todo truco incluso a la
discusión histórica de si esto es un
levantamiento de la izquierda bueno esto
funciona como los huracanes
solucionan toda clase de nubes alrededor
atraen posiciones políticas de distintas
de 22 días actores de distinto tipo
incluso hasta la criminal criminalidad
organizada pero en el fondo es una
realidad hay un proceso de degradación
de degeneración social que implica
también de gran acciones de generación
económica y el estado no muestra la
capacidad de poder atender las
necesidades básicas de la gente claro
que esto genera más ácida está y más
incertidumbre con lo cual tienes el
terreno fértil para que se incremente el
freno económico no hay nada más
espantoso
relativa económica que paula ya le voy a
dar la palabra voy a hacer la ronda a la
inversa voy a continuar con danilo
precisamente preguntándole por quienes
se pueden ver beneficiados por estos
momentos de manifestaciones de
descontento de incertidumbre a quién
beneficia aquí siempre tiene que haber
un ganador y un perdedor en este tipo de
situaciones quien están en beneficiados
en todo tipo de grupos uno de los más
organizados y dos los que tienen el
cálculo político mejor planteado yo soy
de la opinión que hay campañas políticas
que se han ganado con meses y hasta años
de anticipación
y soy de los que piensan que lo que
ocurre en panamá en este momento que ya
está definiendo la suerte electoral aún
cuando no tengamos candidatos qué
significa eso que como ocurrió en chile
y posiblemente como haya podido haber
ocurrido en colombia la suerte electoral
en abril de
2002 en colombiano pues está en panamá
los beneficiarios van a ser los grupos
que puedan capitalizar este disgusto
social enorme de grandes proporciones
y los partidos tradicionales no muestran
estar en sintonía con la sociedad no
muestran ser empáticos al contrario
arrastran toda una serie de acusaciones
en materia de corrupción de desconexión
con la sociedad de oportunismo político
así es que podrán ser organizaciones
políticas que todavía no se prefieran
como políticos u organizaciones que
puedan perfilarse con alguna opción
política en primera instancia podrían
estar los grupos de izquierdas pero no
son los únicos necesariamente también
podrían estar grupo de una derecha
extrema o de una derecha simplemente
claro él está aquí para
capitalizar el discurso si está
coherente y sostenida sustentable de una
organización y pienso que ahora se
comienzan a dar las bases de ese desde
ese triunfo del punto de vista
social hay muy pocos actores que ganan
el prestigio de quienes están mediando
en en este toque son clara iglesia
principalmente la iglesia católica
se está jugando porque hay un debate hay
actores que no se sienten representados
en la mesa que está en conversaciones
ahorita mismo o de seguir todos privados
xxi a participar de esas conversaciones
pero como sigue privado se siente ya
como un potencial perdedor de lo que
está ocurriendo no así el centro
organizado de punto de vista sindical y
de ciertos gremios organizaciones
populares tienen abierta una posibilidad
de identidad y una posibilidad de lucha
que los as
acerque al favor y al reconocimiento de
liderazgo de punto de vista social paula
su opinión sobre este tema sobre quiénes
pueden ser beneficiados esta oportunidad
para capitalizar
posiciones a nivel político también en
otros sectores y esa incertidumbre
política que hay también en la región
sobre todo con algunos países como por
ejemplo brasil en donde van a ir a
elecciones a final de año colombia que
dio un giro
político completamente histórico pero
bueno usted como colombiana sabe mejor
que nadie que colombia es el país de hay
que esperar a ver qué pasa entonces el
país vive esperando a ver qué pasa que
puede que tan fuerte es este sentimiento
de incertidumbre para aumentar este tipo
de descontento no saber cuál es el rumbo
que van a tener los países
bueno pues yo creo que aquí la palabra
de moda siempre ha sido el tema de la
incertidumbre frente a cómo se van dando
las cosas efectivamente y cuáles son
pues las decisiones que los gobiernos de
turno van tomando para calmar pañitos de
agua tibia como decimos acá un poco pues
estas estas medidas y sin embargo pues
quienes ganan evidentemente son apuestas
de tipo político que se hacen frente a
tratar de generar esa incertidumbre o de
tratar de generar pues ese malestar
frente a lo que está sucediendo pero
digamos que aquí también hay una cosa
importante que no hemos mencionado y es
que en últimas también las maneras la
manera como los gobiernos están
respondiendo a esas protestas es lo que
termina generando también pues ese este
grado de molestia y de insatisfacción en
el caso pues de colombia lo vimos en
alguna ciudad de ser de unos mandatarios
locales y en el caso de perú el
presidente castillo pues tomó la
decisión de hacer un toque de que alguna
medida que para muchos pues fue extrema
las imágenes que estamos viendo pues
también de el uso el exceso de la fuerza
para calmar esas manifestaciones pues en
efecto no ayudan a fomentar el diálogo
ni a encontrar esos canales que permitan
entender cómo poder encontrar es un
camino que de respuesta a esa a esta
múltiple cantidad de
requerimientos que se hacen desde la
sociedad en términos sociales en
términos de educación en términos de
salud en el caso por ejemplo pues de lo
que vemos en el catálogo de reformas que
se está proponiendo que proponen los que
se quieren sentar a la mesa de
negociación en panamá incluyen por
ejemplo reducir los costos de la canasta
básica e incluyen designar un porcentaje
importante del pib en materia de
educación
entonces en el caso de colombia pues lo
vimos muy claro quién terminó
beneficiándose de estas manifestaciones
pues es el gobierno que llega
actualmente al poder con un discurso de
de cambio de transformación de no
queremos más de lo mismo y por lo tanto
pues la política finalmente terminó
haciéndose en este tipo de actos y en
unos porque actúan y en otros porque no
actúan acaso méxico en donde al
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador
le critican mucho su falta de acción
frente a los temas de seguridad y al
avance que han tenido los cárteles del
norte del país y el tráfico de drogas y
cómo han tomado fuerza y la muerte de
los periodistas y también los
feminicidios un tema que está
prácticamente fuera de control en méxico
vemos a las mujeres manifestándose en
las calles pidiendo mayor seguridad y
políticas para ellas y el gobierno
simplemente no hace absolutamente nada
esas son las críticas de la sociedad
mexicana me quedan pocos minutos para
finalizar el programa para hacer la
conclusión
quisiera conocer entonces paula y danilo
su opinión si estamos para concluir el
programa si estamos ante un punto de
quiebre de la historia latinoamericana
si esto va a generar un rompimiento un
quiebre a nivel político que la sociedad
va a forzar precisamente para defender
sus intereses
de estas protestas y manifestaciones de
todo tipo que vemos en los diferentes
países de américa latina danilo por
favor muy puntual
yo sí creo que estamos frente un punto
de quiebre por tres razones la primera
porque la gente se está auto convocando
sin liderazgos fuertes y el liderazgo
sin caudillismos y en rasgos
muy llamativos los sectores se convocan
y son capaces de hacer reclamaciones que
desestabilizan que descuadran el estudio
del orden establecido y eso es algo muy
muy muy propio de lo que estamos
viviendo segundo porque el nivel de
tolerancia social ha bajado a un punto
increíblemente un mínimo por lo cual la
gente
y la de la reclamación pueden causar
profundo desajuste si no les están
preocupando grandemente son de lo que
están viviendo ahorita y como una
especie de y ya he perdido tanto pues
que me cuesta pérdida de algo más y
tercero porque la expectativa de mejoría
de la gente no es donde no hay causa
grandes curaciones la gente no se pone a
pensar
y de dónde va a salir el recurso para
tal cosa que estoy pidiendo o para tal
otra cosa que queremos no hay un grado
de exigencia de responsabilidad al ser
tasados a los gobiernos que es
increíblemente alto la responsabilidad
de resolver los problemas históricos y
las coyunturas de crisis le ha llegado
los gobiernos de manera innegable
así que así te lo puedo decir por esos
tres factores creo que estamos en un
punto de quiebre y paula su opinión su
conclusión para el cierre estamos ante
un punto de quiebre de la sociedad
latinoamericana
bueno yo creo que ese punto de quiebre
ya empezó hace mucho en el año 2019 creo
que chile empezó ese liderazgo y como en
un efecto dominó los otros países de la
región pues han seguido digamos en esa
línea estamos entonces ante un momento
en el cual hay una mayor veeduría
ciudadana en un punto en el cual en
efecto como lo es el profesor danilo
pues la ciudadanía se está movilizando
de manera autónoma y no necesariamente
alrededor de intereses políticos
simplemente se están moviendo porque
está viendo afectada su calidad de vida
afectado su día a día y por lo tanto
pues eso eso implica y exige cambios de
parte de los gobiernos gobiernos que
lamentablemente pues no han estado a la
altura de estas transformaciones ni esos
cambios
gobiernos o partidos políticos
tradicionales que se tienen que repensar
que tienen que reajustar sus procesos y
así ser mucho más transparentes en la
manera como toman las decisiones y en la
manera como involucran a esos ciudadanos
que están altamente molestos y
frustrados frente a las decisiones que
están tomando ya que nada cambia pues a
paula a ruiz ya danilo todos les
agradezco mucho por haber hecho este
análisis este tema complejo con
múltiples aristas pero que vamos a
seguir poniéndole la lupa para tratar de
entender conforme se vaya desarrollando
en nuestra región en américa latina'
muchas gracias por haber estado con
nosotros ustedes también muchas gracias
por la sintonía y pueden seguir con la
programación de france 24
[Música]